hello everyone I know it's been
absolutely months and months since I did
a last playthrough but I just thought
I'd come back and do some Arkham Knight
because it still is one of my favorite
games of all time I just love talking
about Batman really I'm a bit rusty
because I haven't played it for
absolutely ages so sorry yeah if I'm not
exactly amazing but you know I've been
playing them dying light which is
absolutely incredible
also played and just as The Witcher 3
I've just had a great time with
Playstation because they've been putting
lots of things on sale and thought I'd
check everything out and so I'm just
kind of getting back into it at the
moment and seeing what I can do in terms
of Batman stuff there's been a
incredible amount of comics come out
recently from Doomsday Clock to the main
run with Tom King to Detective Comics to
batman white knight to more injustice
and it just feels like a really great
time to be a Batman fan there's so much
work out there that is definitely worth
checking out one of the best stories
I've read recently is by Tom King called
I am suicide and it's sort of is about
Batman taking on Bane head to head and
it's very much a sort of sequel to
nightfall there's lots of Limoges in it
such as Batman gets his back broken
well not broken but he gets prior messed
up you know I mean Bane just loves
breaking people's backs so he breaks his
back throws him in the pit that he was
trapped in as a kid and Batman's kind of
got a survive to show he's man enough to
face Bane and it's just a brilliantly
Illustrated comic booth
it it's one of the best things in tom
king's run i think a lot of people
dislike it but when I was reading it I
was absolutely blown away by how good
the artwork was there's a section and
you need to pick up the graphic novel to
really appreciate because I read it
digitally first and it wasn't you know
it was good but it wasn't as
mind-blowing as it was flicking through
it page by page so there's a section
where Batman basically escapes the pit
and goes through Santa Prisca to take
down Bane and he's just working his way
like through every section of it and its
massive splash pages there's hundreds of
gods on it and it's just brilliantly put
together and I definitely recommend that
you pick up Tom Kings run in general
it's not outstanding it's not at the
levels Scott Snyder's was but there's a
lot there's a lot going on I'm a bit
angry at Scott Snyder actually because
in Batman n game the the beginning of it
Batman goes in a suit called the Justice
Buster which is he has to do because the
joke has poisoned the Justice League
with new Joker toxin that's made them go
crazy and want to attack Batman so he
has to take on this suit and then
realized last night that the Justice
Buster it's just a copy off the
Hulkbuster by Iron Man so I was a bit
annoyed but you know comic books is
there's so much plagiarism going on
actually think marbles stole more from
DC than DC of stole from Marble although
the recent movies might might do that so
another thing I'll probably want to talk
about is the recent movie Justice League
and when I first went to see it
I wasn't like I was like yeah it's fine
it's fine I don't know why everyone
hates they're like three shots I should
pick my targets wisely just shoot and
suggest is the first time I watched it I
was like yeah it's fine
the more I've thought about a doctor
again the more ridiculous it is like
there's so many little things in it that
I just don't understand such as Batman
as Superman is dressed up as Clark Kent
at the end of it and it's just like well
didn't this guy die at the end of the
last movie so it's a bit strange like
there's there's so many little things
that they clearly just brush over and
I've actually really gotten into the
Marvel movies recently and I just loved
the way they have like a totally
consistent tone there's no real flaws in
them I mean there's 80 movies that
they've done now and they've done such a
good job of keeping up to date with like
everything going on there's really no
continuity flaws and everything feels
the same totally whereas DC they can't
even seem to keep the same tone in in a
movie let alone 18 yeah the problem with
Justice League I think is you can
clearly see we're just readings coming
in and reshot Zack Snyder's work and it
makes it quite jarring and those scenes
you can easily tell by the fact that
Henry cavils mustache looks horrendous a
lot of people I've spoken to still don't
know but the henry cavill for the
majority of Justice League his mouth is
completely CGI'd and to me it just
looked horrendous I remember when the
movie opened on that cell phone footage
looking at the mouth and thinking geez
this is a 300 million dollar movie and
the mouth looks that bad I was just I
literally sat there thinking I remember
my girlfriend turned and looked at me
and said that is so CGI and I was that
yet that was just horrendous and the
rest of the movie doesn't doesn't match
up to it and I think it's you know
the CGI artists are getting a lot of
stick for it but they really didn't have
time to properly do their job they were
given like a couple of months to go
through in CGI out this mustache from
Henry cabals mouth and it's just a
ridiculous thing basically what happens
is much like DC wanted to do and Warner
Brothers wanted to do reshoots on
justice league because they kind of felt
that Zack Snyder's vision wasn't what
people were after and there's a lot of
rumors floating about at the moment that
Zack Snyder was actually fired from
Justice League before he left like he
had a family tragedy where one of his
children committed suicide and then he
departed from the project but there's
some rumors going about that that was
sort of just nicely put across by Warner
Brothers like they did actually fire him
and so anyway they wanted to do reshoots
and henry cavill is contracted for
Mission Impossible 6 to have a mustache
as part of his character so for some
stupid reason just to be dicks paramount
said that he wasn't allowed to shave for
Justice League and that he had to have a
mustache for the part which is it's
completely ridiculous and Warner was
actually made footage where they CGI'd a
mustache over Henry Cavill II to show
how good it look and apparently it did
look really well and still paramount
more like now that's that's not for us
that so they just they just said no and
Warner Brothers obviously fuming had to
quickly go back in CG out all the CGI
out all of the mustaches and which is
ridiculous well you know it makes for a
funny story to tell people I
unfortunately think it just makes the
movie completely jarring and Ben Affleck
they they got them so right in Batman V
Superman
father killing that I was really excited
to see him return to the role but he
sort of does nothing in in justice
league he's he's very much like a
bystander there's no real point in him
being in the film he almost he's just
like an idiot he rushes into battle see
he's a bad leader it's no match for the
villains and it's just a really it's
just a poor characterization because
being a massive Batman fan I've seen in
comics how they can probably do him in
the Justice League and make him like a
great member of the team and it's
ridiculous though that this happening
when Superman showed up and he was like
I thought you didn't like mean he's like
I do not like you I was just blown away
by how bad that line was and the fact
that they try to force that Clark Kent
and Bruce Wayne had this amazing
friendship is ridiculous because they
were the wind friends at all the [ __ ]
they had a fight and had about two
minutes together
there was no friendship there so I don't
know why I try to play it up like oh
yeah
you know these two lads they were
friends all along so there's a quite a
lot of things in the movie that will
just pour it's a shame because just
Warner Brothers the they're really neat
a hit the Wonder Woman was great and it
would have been brilliant if they had
had a follow up that was just as good
and you know this was an opportunity to
show that they were back on track but
they're just investor and whether you
know it was Snyder's fault or whatever
like it's just a bit ridiculous I love
this bit in the game by the way I love
this whole interrogation scene where you
fighting people as you're interrogating
brilliant it's a huge step up from
Arkham City and Arkham Asylum where you
just do it stand there and tear
but yeah back to Justice League I've
seen a lot of people saying they wanted
the Snyder cut release and look Batman V
Superman the extended cut was absolutely
brilliant but I don't think that an
extended cut of Justice League would do
it any favors
mainly because Snyder never finished the
film it was it was an assembly Kurt
that's that's all that they had they'd
still need to do all the CGI whereas
Batman V Superman they did actually have
all those scenes ready that made it to
the extended cut and Warner Brothers cut
them out at the last minute whereas
which lack Snyder's stuff he bought all
the stuff together but it wasn't
anywhere near completely I think Suicide
Squad kind of made people think that we
will always get extended cuts but we
didn't and to be honest I don't from
what I heard many rumors have said that
Justice League was actually unwatchable
which is quite funny like the original
cut and Joss Whedon pretty much had to
come in and save the movie and which is
quite funny but you know it's coming out
on not it's coming out on blu-ray like
in the next month I think I think it's
out digitally now where I tend to just
wait for the blu-rays and yeah I'm not
looking forward to seeing it that much I
think I've seen it about six times
though so is that fair I be like I'm a
bit bored of seeing this film but yeah
it's just a shame I kind of wish DC
would just get their act together on it
but you know it well it's not really
DC's fall DC elds is you do have their
act together but it's Warner Brothers
kind of messing stuff up I don't think
Zack Snyder should have been given as
much control as he was like
Warner Brothers have this weird thing
where if someone messes up on a movie
they still give them like another chance
ie like Man of Steel I enjoyed the movie
but a lot of critics hey there
it didn't make very much money and then
they decided give him Batman V Superman
and that messes up and then they decided
to give him Justice League as well I
know his wife is like one of the
executives at Warner Brothers but like
what if someone kept messing up like
Nightwing yeah yeah each one of Batman's
best mate because he didn't [ __ ] up he
doesn't [ __ ] up the lad
if Nightwing was axe neither he would
have been dead on the first night I
don't want to fully rip the guy apart
because I know he has gone through
tragedy which is very very sad now do
you like his movie i movies are
absolutely loved The Watchmen Isle of
Man of Steel and Batman V Superman yes I
do but a lot of people don't but what
extended cuts yes absolutely love this
bit this is why the game is so good
because Mark Hamill does such a
fantastic job of delivering every single
line and it's a shame that The Killing
Joke that he did doesn't live up to this
and I don't have to have discussed it on
the night playthrough before but he
seems very tired very bored throughout
it I would my friend and I Tom cui and
we do a podcast for watching The
Watchmen and we took a where we
basically break down the Watchmen
graphic novel page by page and we did
the graphic novel The Killing Joke as a
there's a half term half season breaking
and mid-season break I think they call
in America so yeah we sanded that and
the work so good and it's a shame man
you know the perfect people for a Kevin
Conroy and it's the most invincible
machine gun ever they got to do this
movie that the both said they waited
their entire career to do and they just
kind of sucked and which mainly was to
the fact that there was a Barbara Gordon
hour long story line before it were deer
meat it's got some of the worst lines
ever in it it's got like one of the
villains says to Barbara Gordon oh is
that at that time at a month you just
think oh wow this is you know Alan Moore
or the original one of the best comic
book authors of all time and you think
that lines like that I'm gonna you know
be be welcome in a project like this
yeah it was just a bad decision
it's a shame because it's one of those
movies that I waited ages for and and
just to see how bad it disappoint you
know I've kind of went off the well I
was kind of going off the DC animated
movies and then I heard that rotten by
gas that was coming out and it was
getting like really bad reviews upon
release but when I watched it I really
enjoyed it and I recommend that people
check it out I mean if you're watching
this video chances are you you probably
are quite interested in Batman so I
definitely recommend that you check it
out it it's probably not as good as the
original graphic novel but there's
there's a lot of stuff in there that
makes it worth checking out and it's
you know it's got a different ending so
if you have read the graphic novel it's
it still gonna stand on its own I love
how this is a blimp mission as well one
of the the best aspects of the Gotham
skyline is always the blimps it's kind
of always had this 1920's noir feel to
it and this is like brilliant to be
doing a mission on it
so there's Simon Stagg and his blimp a
little bit of trivia for you in my
personal life I'm actually going on my
stag do very soon and another little bit
of trivia for you I'm dressing up as
Nightmare Batman and it's gonna be a
great you know nightmare Batman from
Batman V Superman the big trenchcoat
flash version of Batman yeah I'm so
rusty on these controls I'm sorry and
yeah I think it's gonna be just a fun
night I might post a quick video on my
youtube just showing what my costume
looks like because you know it's gonna
be a good night for all involved and
including me Pervis Lee done fancy dress
I'm not a big fan of it but I just
thought like if I do then there's no
chance that I can get you know [ __ ]
over if I'm choosing the costume because
you know some of these lads that might
dress me up as Wonder Woman or something
which I'm not I'm not up for so yeah be
good and it was it wasn't very difficult
getting them a mask I thought I've seen
some of the money at sea there were like
three or four hundred quid and I saw the
trench coats they were [ __ ] expensive
as well but a man should just find them
like last minute and quickly sniper bid
on them which I'm really happy with I
don't know what I'm gonna be doing here
beyond
I've totally forgotten the plot of this
game and what I'm gonna do but you know
we're just getting by being Batman so
yeah it's gonna be a good night getting
dressed up as Batman and just said
relating with my friends another thing
speaking of weddings Batman's actually
getting married in the comics now -
Selina Kyle which will it be good
Tom Kings in charge where he does a
brilliant work when it's personal
stories there's a one called Batman
rooftops that he did that was basically
it takes place over the space of a night
and it's about Batman and Catwoman
having one last night together before he
takes her to jail which you know we're
all being in that predicament
it's how I met my wife so here that
that's a really good storyline and it
sort of deals with the conflict of
Batman and the woman that he loves and
does he take her in she does actually
get away and there's another storyline
that's a sequel to it which it's almost
like an else world where Batman has to
deal with getting not a normal life with
Selina he doesn't really have to deal
with it but wanna where one of the
characters gets cancerous to go all
there and it's a really heartfelt thing
of like losing the one you love and I
just fell almost head over heels with
the story because it was so well
presented the arts brilliant and it's
one of those things that everyone we
like can really relate to recently my
grandfather passed away and it's nice
that there's so many works where people
deal with death and losing someone and
present in a fictional way that really
allows you to accept what's happened
and add sort of context to your own loss
so I definitely recommend checking out
that Catwoman story because it delivers
on so much of that that work and
goodwill and just you know we're all
gonna die one day which is really sad
but there's so much joy to still be
taken from life that it makes it it
makes it all worth it in the end
and my granddad I was very lucky he had
a very peaceful passing and we all got a
call and were able to to go there and be
with him in his final moments and there
wasn't any pain or anything you just
slowly went to sleep and I was an
atheist before it happened and it really
has changed my perspective on everything
because there were so many little things
that happened through the day that
changed my mind towards how life and
death is I'm no longer a believer of you
know that there's nothing when you die
because I've sort of seen the
transformative process process that he
went through and has just changed me for
the better and it's nicer you know
Batman also has storylines like there
that can help people get through things
like it helped with me I can so yeah
it's nice that this work out there like
that this is getting a very dour and
personal reflective story O'Neil wanted
to play a half an hour about man yeah I
love this part of the game anyway
because it's so are you getting your
gadgets and stuff out on you I've
recently massively gotten to Iron Man
after watching the the Marvel films as I
mentioned earlier and just seeing all
the [ __ ] that Iron Man has like
constantly back to it makes me angry
that the the film version of Batman
doesn't have it and but Iron Man's
basically got a contingency plan for
everything
I love how in the Marvel movies as well
he never puts his suit on the same way
in any movies there's always like a new
and inventive way for him to get into
the suit and every movie gets cooler and
cooler
and I kind of wish that would transfer
over to the the character of Batman in
the Justice League films than that but
Arkham Knight there's a brilliant job of
doing it where they constantly get
basically everything target the soldier
controlling the drone they make
everything really high-tech and it's
just incredible all the little things
that you get I'm sure this is the only
time in the game you can actually do
this because I've tried it before and it
just didn't work but never mind and so
anyway that was my playthrough of Batman
Arkham Knight I know it has been
electron hours and hours and hours since
I've been waiting for this that you've
been waiting for this sorry but you know
we've got all got busy lives and I'm a
famous youtuber now so do you think I
have time to be playing [ __ ] like this
all the time I don't so thanks very much
for checking out the video and I'll see
you next time take care peace
you